they still live my life a quarter mile
at a time but things changed our Father
now I will always be in your heart
little Brian I have a gift for you your
daddy gave me this no I'm gonna give it
to you it's very special it's for
protection from what's coming
all right down what's next no matter how
fast you walk
compared to you know not rugs their past
crying your festival coming and mine
just caught up to me been a long time
don't
[Music]
so we're up against a master thief
high-performance driver
whoo easy
[Music]
Jacob is Dom's brother your whole life
you pushed yourself to be faster than
Donna smarter than down stronger than
time but could you kill him
because I'm ready if you are
[Music]
there's nothing more powerful than the
love of family you turn that into anger
there's nothing more dangerous maybe
this is the end but we won't go out
together you know I'd ride to the death
with you
[Music]
it's good to work please tell me that's
not a pontiac fiero strapped to a rocket
engine impressive I know no no that's
that's not in for us
I came here to take you down a little
god that's your mistake
this is my world
damn they got a magnet plane hold on
tell me you're not thinking what I think
you're thinking there's no bread Oh
[Music]
hey guys surprise
nice Clubhouse
you